Well yeah, I was gonna ask you, which was harder or challenging for you:...
...living together or adjusting to the new environment, which is Tokyo?
I think we were very excited to move to Tokyo, that it wasn't difficult.
We were sort of open to, as much as possible you know,...
...go in this taxi,...
...and go in this subway.
You know, most people will be scared,...
...but it's like once we learned which lines to take,...
...we were completely open to, sort of, living the life of a Japanese citizen.
Japanese citizens?
It wasn't difficult at all.
It wasn't difficult?
No.
I mean, it was hard like,...
...you know, when we were trying to get to like Sony Music, for instance.
We had to do the train station by ourselves.
Yeah. Sometimes, we get a little bit lost 'cause, you know, we can't quite read Japanese,...
...but we are so excited that we launched first in Japan.
You know, we think the culture is amazing.
The music that they produce is just awesome.
We're so happy that, you know, we're always in and they keep bringing us back.
It's such a great thing to listen to those nice things from Japan.
We can be criticized.
Nobody in EastWest Boys.
We really have had just like a really positive experience from Japan.
And I think it has a lot to do with,...
...you know, the people you work with through Sony,...
...but, you know, the people we meet on the streets are so nice.
We think that everybody's really hardworking here,...
...very respectful and so we're just happy to be here.